President Biden travels to Northern
Ireland today for ceremonies to Mark the
25th anniversary of a landmark peace
deal new tensions in that British
Province threatened to undermine the
settlement police in one city were
attacked with fire bombs yesterday
Charlie dagada has more from Northern
Ireland
[Music]
young protesters pelted a police car
with Molotov cocktails
the only only incidents of violence we
saw in an otherwise peaceful if illegal
Catholic Republican parade in
Londonderry
that followed a ceremony from the other
side of the rocky political divide a
Protestant parade in Belfast no
surrender
these parades take place every year at
Easter time but with tensions Rising
once again here in Northern Ireland
they've taken on added significance
counter-terrorism police uncovered an
IRA bomb plot to coincide with the
president's visit according to the
Belfast Telegraph the terrorism threat
had already been raised from substantial
to severe meaning an attack is now
highly likely from Ira Affiliated groups
an attack of some sort is deemed to be
potentially imminent but that's not a
threat against the U.S president because
for years you know For Better or For
Worse they have had significant support
from the United States but the
heightened alert follows the attempted
murder of a high-profile police officer
shaking a fragile piece as President
Biden marks a 25th anniversary of the
Good Friday agreement the U.S broker
deal which largely brought an end to
Decades of violence that cost the lives
of more than 3 500 people
I think there's a lot of people who will
be very enthusiastic to see Joe Biden I
think so I think it'll be very warmly
received and Ireland being a small
country you know feels flattered by the
attentions of a big country like in
America
the president
we're heading south for a three-day
visit there Gail
Charlie dagada reporting from Northern
Ireland we thank you